hey guys welcome back to the swoosh what
led podcast yes what lad is proudly
sponsored by swoosh which is a super
cool platform which lets you the fans
connect with some of your favorite
sports stars as a young hurricane fan
growing up i had an obsession with
christian cullen and a video shout out
from the goat would have been the
greatest present ever unfortunately back
then i did have to settle for a poster
but thanks to swish the old posters can
now be turned into a video message will
last a lifetime to order head over to
heyswoosh.com and you can get 10 percent
off by using the code what a lad but the
very best bit of it all is that at least
20 off every video goes to kiwi kids
charities such a good cause and it's
definitely worth getting behind
and also puresport cbd have been helping
waterlab listeners with any muscle or
joint pain for well over a year now it
is the most tested and trusted cbd oil
on the planet with pro athletes all
around the world using it it is the
ideal natural alternative for any
athlete who is smashing back more than
one anti-inflammatory a week and of
course it does have zero thc in it if
you want to give it a try you can use
the code water lad 20 and get an extra
20 off your order and i'll leave a link
in the description so you can just click
on that and lastly everyone's favorite
lad tim bateman has been offering an
awesome opportunity for anyone who's
interested in their wellness
oh studio is new zealand's largest
wellness and recovery space and there is
now an exciting opportunity for you to
own your very own
anyone who knows tim bateman will know
that he's one of the most switched on
guys you'll ever meet so having him
guide you through this whole process of
setting up your own business is
priceless within itself
add to the fact that the wellness space
is the second fastest growing industry
in the world this is an awesome
opportunity for anyone who likes to run
their own ship or is excited for
something new if you are interested
click on the link in the description to
get in touch
and as always i'm super grateful for all
our sponsors who are helping bring this
podcast to you
but we will get to the main act because
this one is a good one
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
what a lad well today i have a legend of
the game on the podcast who has had some
career he's almost done it all he's
played for north harbor the blues otago
and the highlanders he's also
represented his country in both the
seven man game and for of course the all
blacks he also spent some time over the
uk where he became a leicester legend
and going off what every single person
i've spoken to has said he is one of the
greatest lads going around it is the
great craig newby welcome mate oh mate
what an introduction and uh
apart from the technical difficulties
i'm not allowed in the in the computer
world mate we've struggled here for the
last 10 minutes but
great to be honest great to be on
mate stoke to get through that little
technical difficulty and um get you on i
love hearing stories about the golden
era of professional rugby and um no
doubt you have plenty yeah well i was
having a bit of a think because a couple
of the boys at the club here on over in
belfast they they listen to the podcast
as well we've got a couple of kiwi guys
and
or one kiwi one aussie and
um so yeah i was sort of thinking of
some stories the other day but i guess
until you start getting into them it's
hard to remember them all and after half
the time you pissed anyway and you don't
remember them anyway
yeah that's so true but one thing a lot
of people did want to know going from
the questions was what you're up to now
like it's been a while since you've been
out of the game so what have you been up
to post rugby
yeah it's been nearly 10 years since i
retired um
bad knees so knees blew out on me and
just had to give up and um so i've been
over in the uk
after that and the last sort of nine 12
months i've been over in
belfast coaching at ulster so
somehow landed at the uh skills coach
working with jared payne who's the
defense coach everyone know jp and a guy
called dan soper who's charlie hall's
best mate from down at alexandra so
real good crew of coaches here so that's
my last 12 months is just uh trying to
learn how to coach and
try not to make mistakes and trying to
add value yeah what have you found the
biggest difference from coaching to
playing oh
probably with the way you talk to people
like you and the way you you you treat
everyone like as a player you just sort
of ripped in and led from the front and
if something needed to be said you'd say
it but
as a coach you've got to be a little bit
more tactful and think about how that
might come across and how it wants to
come across to the players so i've found
that probably in the last 12 months
really
really challenging and something i've
really enjoyed
initially it was
having an idea that i knew that
could be done but players you know
couldn't do it or couldn't you couldn't
coach it across to them so i found that
initially but yeah that's that's been a
struggle but i mean i love it i love the
coaching
and i've been on the sideline i'll do
the water and run the tea on or hobble
the tea on and i just love being part of
the footy and we had it we were in
toulouse on the weekend and absolutely
30 000 people in their stadium just
going mad mainly at the referee because
he was he well i thought he was
brilliant but they didn't think he was
and
i just love being a part of footy and
you know i just sit down at the end of
it one lose draw and have a bear and
share the stories and
um that's why i'm still in it but yeah
doing it over here in belfast i live on
my own here i've got little
nice place in east belfast and you're
enjoying that
do you miss playing sounds like it
oh
there's days i miss the atmosphere of
playing like the big games you know i
wish i was there to to enjoy that but
i don't miss waking up while i do still
wake up i saw back and saw knees and my
neck and
but no i don't miss it that although
last year i was a couple years ago i was
home um
during cover times my mum was a bit
crook so i came home to help out the old
man massive basically cooking dinners
because he's pretty hopeless and um
came home to support mom and dad and i
ended up
my brother-in-law plays for kokura where
did he coaches them and he said oh we
have to watch the chiefs islanders game
we're going to meet at the the pub at
nine in the morning jump on the bus
across to hamilton come for a few bears
like yeah awesome
so
sinking beers down
in rotorua in the pub and um get on the
bus at help us nine had six pairs
already and feeling good and
we get over there and we've stopped off
at um like hamilton old boys maybe or
one of the clubs and they're like oh we
just got a golden oldies game
before the the highlanders chiefs game
so do you want to play i was like nah
[ __ ] that i'm not playing knees gone i
can't play and i've got some boots i was
like oh no no
anyway
four more bears and i've had a dozen
beers here and
the guitar's out proper
so anyway i go
i'll go 16th man within the first minute
someone's injured i end up playing the
whole game
and
i absolutely loved it so
up until that point i hadn't missed
rugby at all but
i just
got a skin full and just got the fever
it was golden i was over 40s and there
was one bloke who was going terry turbos
and me and my brother or brad we're like
let's get them so we smashed this one
guy and i got sucked into it and then
ended up throwing a try and i was so
good so good and then i went to the went
to the chiefs game and it was beautiful
and nice afternoon it was a game where
the chiefs were up by a million at half
time
and everyone was giving me a load of
[ __ ] and then hollanders dragged it back
and i remember seeing grant fox and uh
they're the classic hey foxy and he
turned around and just like we all just
blanked them and he didn't know who it
was and he's looking to the crowd and
just one of those days but um
that's the only game i've had in 12 or
10 years scored a try smash that you're
on fire i love it
one bloke was about 70 and he come
flying into this rock and just caught my
elbow and he well i mean he might have
caught it right whatever but he come up
with this massive cut he must have
needed
ten stitches and he was
so he was pretty old so old he had the
gold shorts on and that and um yeah but
he just he just he ran off taped himself
back up with some insulation tape
through a cut and just loved it and just
straight back into it
i guess that's the like
that like none of them not that i you
know i'm pretty modest but none of them
knew i was an ex or black or who you
know who were of ours or just some
blokes just having bears and at every
water break the the sheep
french gun would come out and you'd have
shot support
and at the at the aftermath function it
was pretty nice we had a big massive
feed and um
i don't know what happened but one of
the guys the their captain found must
have found out and then the speeches
just said oh awesome you know having all
black in here and
you know play the game and have a few
beers and stuff so that was that was
pretty cool i'm just getting
acknowledged
for that so was it your knees that ended
your career and what was that how bad
was that it was my knees in the end um i
was still playing really good footy for
leicester we'd made um
we'd lost the final to harlequins that
year and i well tragically i didn't i
didn't play in the final i had pretty
bad knees and i wasn't training a lot
and i played the semi-final against
saracens and and i got man of the match
and then this the final got put on the
bench i was pretty bitter about it
so yeah that was that was it really and
that was my last game i kind of knew it
was my last game and
um i didn't it didn't even get put on
and i was pretty filthy and i didn't see
the final like two minutes of the game i
just
well you know like
i just went into the change rooms and
probably acted quite poorly and
respected you know looking back i
probably should have dealt with that
better but i knew it was my last game i
just in my heart i knew i had i had
off-season clean-outs planned or booked
in but i just knew it was my last game
and
i remember going to change room and
julian white lots of got him prop he um
he didn't get on either and we just sat
and then we had a bear and then
[ __ ] murphy's law the drug testers
come over and like uh number 19 and
numbered whatever and you're drug
testing i told this guy to [ __ ] off and
he said i was out of are you denying a
test and i said i'm not denying a test
man i've just [ __ ] one lost the final
two not got on i'm certainly having to
be with my mate just like and he's like
well if you're gonna refuse i'll put you
down as a
as a refusal and that's gonna go as a
two-year ban and you know where i ended
up
i took like two hours to take a person
just to spite him really
so that was it yeah so just cartilage
really i had a few tidy ups over over my
time and eventually they ran out of
options um
and yeah i'm in for a knee but double
knee replacement i've actually got a
surgery
um appointment tomorrow with a surgeon
and then hopefully getting them done
this year
which should be good new pair of wheels
how good you'll be back out there in no
time
but man they're so disappointing to hear
what fairy tale finished like a lot of
guys always sort of dream about the
perfect way to end their career but
obviously you're one was not quite like
that no but i i don't have any regrets
and i remember richard cochran was the
coach and
he eventually got moved on from
leicester i rang him just to say thanks
for his time you know and i like how
they've done it like the club didn't
really go about it that well and
he just said no thanks for your you know
all your effort and you know you all the
games you played for me were
you know like you always gave your best
and that was quite a nice compliment and
then he just apologized for not putting
me on in the final he said you know like
one of my regrets so
yeah it's one of those things and uh
someone's gotta win and someone's gonna
lose and and on that day it was it was
harlequin's and a lot of people talk
about how hard um those first couple
years are post retirement how did you
find that
um
i don't know really i like
you can sit around and and feel sorry
for yourself or mope or like no fine
excuses but not to get out of bed or to
i was on all this money and now i'm not
and whatever but i was pretty lucky i
had um
pretty good investment since my my
parents were really good at advising me
with my money so i had a little bit of
money tucked away and i invested in some
property and i okay there so
financially i was okay so i was lucky i
know some guys aren't in that same boat
but yeah i just made a plan i wanted to
be a coach and i said right what i need
to do and so i was coaching at schools
and i ended up getting a national one
gig with cambridge and
doing after dinner speaking and just
working my ass off for an opportunity
and eventually got to japan
had a year in at the green rockets and
then came back and
so i didn't give myself time to
to dwell i just made some goals and like
how can i how can i achieve though
um
that was that was it really i suppose um
didn't have time to
to suck about it that's uh and how did
you find coaching uh the green rockets
oh the rockets made that i loved it um
for lots of reasons after i
i decided you know it took me two or
three months to decide that i wasn't
going to change some of the stuff that
i'm trying to do on and off the field
and just embrace it and and i started
finding ways that i could influence the
players and the play and and i you know
i just
got i had some good
good buggers there that guy called nick
ross who's from waikato second row neil
brew old bruiser from
back in the hollander's days was playing
and um so we had a if he was samuel 9
aussie guy and scott higginbotham so i
just really went through those guys and
where our captain
spoke good english so i kind of just cut
the japanese coaches out a little bit
and try to focus on what i could control
and
i had some awesome nights out in tokyo
with some of the boys and like we you
know jump on the train and
like just all you can drink and
whatever's real cheap and then i
remember like going in to meet orlando
sarkoy and a few boys once and i left my
my bag i got that personal left my bag
in the taxi and i was [ __ ]
i wasn't know where are you like i
didn't know where i was and he ended up
somehow he got on the phone and he found
the last taxi he rang this the number
and he spoke fluent japanese and that's
got within half an hour the guys dropped
my bag back and it was yeah i love this
love the place good food good people
footy was
tough we got into the relegation battle
and we ended up beating dokamo i think
to get through and we saved the club but
um they're struggling a bit too now
boris stankovic's one of my good mates
is over there coaching there oh yeah and
uh he loves it as well they're
struggling a bit
yeah they're definitely struggling they
haven't won a game for about two or
three years now so
maybe since you left
ah they look they won two because the
other team got covered
yeah that's right and all the coaches
are celebrating yeah
yeah claim it
yeah yeah
thank you
oh mate well anyway um we can't get
through a late episode without hearing
the story from the start so pretty keen
to hear what life was like for you
growing up so give us the rundown yeah
life was pretty good i um started footy
for kahukura my local club when i was
four under fives i started playing when
i was four and we lived in the city then
and i think when i was about eight or
nine moved out to the countryside i
remember just getting home from school
and dad was like oh we're moving oh yeah
we were going i would just jump in the
truck and
we drove out and and ended up on a farm
just outside of ritter and
probably the best thing for me like i
was a kid who had loads of energy and i
wasn't that keen on school and got in
trouble a bit and so being on the phone
was really good um when i was about 12
or 13 uh me and a mate ian were out
shooting
sparrows and
pigeons and stuff with the air rifle and
he
he shot me in the leg so i spent a few
weeks in hospital and
had to do an operation a long story he
reckons it wasn't loaded it was
definitely loaded and
so that's what take me a bit i went from
a number eight to i came out of that and
spent
i don't know six months rehab and then i
came out as a fly half so that shaped my
uh kicking and passing ability and
um went to radar boys used to catch the
school bus would take me about an hour
and a quarter hour and a half to get
into school just to get to rotorua boys
because that that was where rugby and
cricket was yeah um western heights was
my other option but they didn't have
cricket and i was more of a i was a real
keen cricketer in those days and i love
my loving my footy but um crooked was my
main passion so i went to rotara boys
drew the national final in 1997
or eight or something like that with
richie mccaw as otago boys richie mccoy
and felipe o'levy and jason powell and
because me and tom donnelly were the
rotara boys
sort of got through the landers
so we drew five all no extra time
because we were playing at jade stadium
and
harbor canterbury were playing before us
after us in the tv times it was bit was
[ __ ] really we drew that
so yeah that was it really just a
typical sort of kiwi kid upbringing
beach in the summer and footy and
cricket um parents were awesome their
older sister was um we didn't get on at
all like we were we hate each other
until
um until she left school and
we become good mates you know like so
we're still good mates i spoke to her
just before
so that was it really and then i i
didn't play much rep stuff i played a
little bit of bay secondary schools but
not really i was
i don't know i was a skinny flanker who
just went hard and loved it and um i
played bay in the 19s when i was still
at school my brother-in-law and our
brother-in-law was playing for the bay
19s and i came and went along to watch
and a couple of guys didn't turn up so i
just jumped on and did it real good and
i remember going to play in taupo
against ken country and we had a had a
court session i didn't know what a court
session was and i i went real hard from
the start and blew out and i remember
just being sick all through like my bed
and that
that was the first real big footy piss
up and i just remember [ __ ] i was like i
need to throw myself out and then
i don't know if you remember there was
like the new zealand rugby academy
no i don't remember that they had a
three-year deal down in palmy and you
did like four or five camps every year
and i scraped my way into that because
i'd made a sort of
inadvertently sort of made the new
zealand sevens yeah um which is quite an
interesting story but
i remember making the new zealand
academy and that was the first time i'd
really ever had any performance training
or never been to the gym
and you would go down to palmy for three
or four days and he's got like who was
in my group tony woodcock mills molina
irini ie
justin wilson oh i can't even remember
now a long time ago shanapaku maybe
and we used to just go down and just
train like just get through the training
and then go straight into the fits and
just have
pints and jugs and the fits down near
the pub and it was good uni town
and i remember one time we got we got
there and it was um they were going for
the world record of jim beam bottles in
the night and said well we're into this
because jim beam went i don't know jim
beam was a big thing when we were young
like that you just jim beam ice
scoot the ice out throw it on the floor
throw it out throw it at someone and
then just chop your jim beam so we we
got involved in this world record
attempt and uh
i think it was like i remember getting
to 99 and everyone was counting down
that like when the 100th bottle came off
the wall and we're all like that line
ended up and we're just chopping we're
wrecked
and we got home like six in the morning
and we had a session with um
with tony gilbert and wayne smith who
were in and around the all black scene
and like we were just
the tear we couldn't catch a cold
couldn't listen to instructions couple
of guys were in the corner sick some
guys didn't turn up
and it was just a debacle and um brendan
ratcliffe i think was the guy who ran it
and he i remember him just ripping into
us tearing it to us and we used to get
three grand
cash a year and you get all these trips
and your kit and stuff and
that was year one and then that was it
they canned it so we didn't even do year
two and three after that um
world record attempt but we we on the
board got over 100 bottles it wasn't
just us obviously about 100 bottles of
gym beam and a night world record
how many people were there oh it was
rammed it was it was packed
um it was packed but i just the last
thing i remember is it getting to 100 it
could have gone more but i don't know
we'll never know
we're meant to play games and everything
like we were going to be a team to play
games but just got the whole thing just
fell apart after that oh you're not
taking it seriously and
it's just kind of the era we're in we're
in between that kind of school boy we uh
play first fifteen go to a party
and professionalism was sort of just
kicking off so we kind of got caught in
between that and that's where i you know
like what i enjoyed you know play hard
work hard play hard kind of
scenario certainly sound like you did
that so you mentioned a little bit about
the new zealand sevens and being on the
fringe of that how did that one come
about from
plenty under 19s was it
no well that under 19 was i was just
sliding i was still at school um but no
the
new zealand sevens used to do the trial
at a 50-man camp or whatever in rotorua
and i was at my level's luncheon first
fifteen on a school leavers luncheon on
a friday
and gordon titchens had run a headmaster
who was chris grinter who was jonah
jonah's coach at wesley
anyway he rang and said look i need
three or four boys to you you know got
three or four boys to come down
fill in some numbers we're gonna have
like a a tournament we need like a
certain amount of players so
he come over to me and a few others and
said hey boys you want to go down monday
as blah blah blah i was like yeah i'll
be at what time and like eight o'clock
or whatever
on the monday i think i was the only one
who turned up out of the four boys that
got invited anime it was first first
thing was beep test
and i was
my resident fit young fellow but beep
test and i got like a 12 or something
like that did okay
half an hour after the beep test finish
was three 1k runs
so 15 minutes in between runs so i've
run them and i'm like struggling
then we did like shuttles and then it
was two on ones for about an hour it was
the worst first day of my life and
it was i was living out of town but
they're like oh look we need you to stay
at the hotel because you've got four
three days i'm like [ __ ] i can't get
through three days of this
and
they didn't have any spare room so i had
to sleep on um sleep on the floor in
eric rush's room they got me this like
[ __ ] blow up mattress a pillow and
like a sheet and i just had to lie on
this thing for three nights but
and then day two and three i think was
games and it was like i was in the blue
team or whatever and just played and it
was at the rotor international stadium
and i actually really enjoyed that
sort of thing like playing against
adults and you know guys like dallas
seymour and owen scrummager and you know
some some real greats from the from the
era and
i'd imagine guys like bruce rahanna and
sam nanoa and damon corona and you know
that kind of
that kind of guy who were playing on the
circuit and then on the thursday or
whatever it was
they're like right wrap it all up wait
on everybody we're going to name the
team and then everyone else can shoot
home whatever and
i just left i was like sweet i just left
i didn't even hear the team announcement
and then
got like got home i could hardly walk i
was almost crying mum picked me up like
i was doing dry i know if i could drive
but i i was so sore i couldn't drive mum
picked me up and i was almost crying i'm
like i couldn't move
and so she took me to like a doctor and
she's like something's wrong with him
he's i was like so you know i end up
going to a massage therapist i never had
a massage before in my life and this
guy's like couldn't even touch me
without me squirming anyway then get a
phone call and
it's
the the manager of the team saying look
craig's meant to be in camp um he's been
selected for the new zealand sevens
um
like wherever he's just shot through
and she's like
he didn't say anything about that
and uh as it turned out i'd done okay on
these four days and made the squad
so i had to go back and i thought i
wasn't so much i wasn't bits
so i um i went back and went into camp
and yeah that was my amusement center
just took an opportunity just turned up
fronted
crazy right that is unreal yeah right
a young kid playing with all the legends
oh mate it was so good it was so good um
i had two years or two years on the
circuit and i didn't play many in the
first year i think i played japan and
maybe fiji or fiji was my definitely my
first tournament
and then the second year played every
every
tournament in that circuit and we won
that one that circuit on my real good
story that i wanted in that first world
series thing the last one was in paris
and we flew to la on the way for a
stopover and then we met this guy i
can't remember his name but he was this
rich kiwi guy and he said look he took
us out for lunch he said if you win the
the series
on your way back i'll take you out on
like on the piss and you know i'll shout
you all this and what is sweet and we
got over there went to we had to make
the final and fiji had to not make the
final and samoa beat them in the
semi-final and we got through and we
ended up we beat smile we won the
tournament and
we went we went back through la and we
stopped in la for four days just me and
chris masoe rodney suarello eric rush
jared going uh justin wilson would
definitely would have been there damian
cronin carl tanana you know i'm picking
names out my ass here but this guy takes
us out onto his yacht and we go out to
catalina island and we're we're on like
i've never touched champagne i didn't
know what champagne was we're drinking
champagne fizzing it up over each other
there was like
prostitutes on the boat there was like a
jacuzzi and there was a jet ski and it
was ridiculous there's a chef and we're
just pissing it up and we're on this jet
ski and we're doing bombs and
swimming around and like just
playing up for the whole day and he
eventually he arrives later on he like
jet turned and he's like get out of the
water i'm like [ __ ] what do you mean
he's like what are you doing in the
water i'm like well done i like we
found it quite strange there's so many
boats all parked out there it was a
beautiful 30 degrees
crystal clear water and there was no one
in the water the whole day and when i
[ __ ] was weird maybe they don't know
doing bombs over here or whatever
but it was shark breeding great white
shark breeding season
and there's sharks warning area they
come up the coast of california and they
breed there
and no one had told us and we're in the
water all day we could have easily we
didn't see a shark but
that was crazy so that was
yeah sevens was awesome i absolutely
loved it it was real work your ass off
and then have a party
um normally the sort of second weekend
of you'd go away and you'd go like i
know singapore and hong kong or
you know
i think it was brisbane in wellington
whatever the second weekend was just a
massive party and i made some awesome
mates through through that guys like
julian huxley and all in australia a guy
called freddie aselin from canada we
became real good mates and we used to
just
just wait for that last after that last
tournament just uh rip into it was
awesome
i love my sevens because titch was
always pretty um serious and quite
strict with all of that sort of
professionalism side of things leading
up to the first obviously till you
finish playing your tournament say and
then um it's a bit of a let your hair
down moment when you're having those big
parties but i didn't know they were that
extravagant on the boat with jet skis
and champagne and for aussies jesus
oh mate that was um
i wouldn't say the norm but
the party
the parties were bloody good egg but
titch was good you know like he was like
you say he was
he wanted a level of fitness that was
you know exceeding what your body was
capable of and
you had to come into camp getting a 13
on a beep test or you you wouldn't even
get to day two he'd send you home so
um i think that's where i learned to
organize self-organize and just work
really hard and i used to
you know somewhere at the mount at mount
mongolia and i'd get up every morning
regardless if i had beers or not and i'd
run round the mount
and i'd try and beat
the time and then i'd go for a swim and
then i'd come home at breakfast and in
the evening do the same thing just but
go the other way and it was not a matter
it was like 14 minutes i think was my
record but
i just you just come and fit and if you
weren't then you wouldn't play and titch
was awesome like that and but he was
really good on like the social side of
things you know we'd always do
excursions and would be out and about
and then go to the commonwealth games
and we went straight into the in
manchester and we went into the village
and the sevens was the last two days of
the whole thing
and we went there quite early and um
first day were just walking around like
buzzing out everyone had like two
haircuts and
getting all the free condoms and eating
mcdonald's and he was like doing his nut
because he was so like want us to eat
properly and sleep and we're like up to
11 at these parties and discos and
people getting winning gold medals and
we're like just
so
the straw broke when when one of the
kiwi um lawn bowls guys
he got but souped up he had been kicked
he'd been like kicked out of his
competition before the opening ceremony
and he got pissed up for two or three
days and he wasn't flying back and he
ended up touching up some like athlete
and there was a complaint and so he got
sent home
and then titch was like that was the
straw like there's too much distraction
so he pulled us out of the village and
we went and stayed in a hotel out of
town
until the tournament
which i think was the best thing for us
because we were just
we're all young fathers and
in the days so many distractions and
like some of these athletes like men and
women just walking past and you're like
[ __ ] like they were
you know they trained four years for it
we traded in four weeks you know and so
we moved out
and then we didn't even make so we
played the final against fiji and we won
the gold and um
we went back on the bus to get changed
and that we met some the kenyan like
some kenyan team not rugby but just the
kenyans and we spent an hour on this bus
doing hakas and and
two teenagers and they were doing like
kenyan songs and
we didn't even make the closing ceremony
we just went straight to the party with
the kenyans and ended up with the new
zealand netball girls the kenyans and
the kiwi rugby guys and we just had the
best night ever it's so good
it's pretty good
bruce didn't take off his gold medal for
like three days
that is good times and that game you
guys were playing against a stacked um
fiji side too in that final way yeah oh
they're always stacked a and sevens you
know like they're just a factory of
sevens but yeah they had like wasalis
review
those two spring to mine i can't quite
remember but um
[Music]
one of them got sent off like in the
first half
and it was really weird like they you
know we wanted to win fair and square
and at the time when there was like it
was a late hit on something brad fleming
got late hit i think and russia must
have been captain and he went to the
referee said don't send him off like
put him in the bin two minutes or
whatever and said just do not send him
off and the rift is like no it was bad
send them off and it was quite
quite sad really it sort of killed it a
bit but then they they were winning at
the time by a score or whatever and then
they got a penalty shortly after and
they took a shot at gold cerebri took a
shot of gold and went up like eight
points he's like i thought i think he
must have thought if we can get two
scores ahead and just hold on then it
might have been enough but we you end up
winning that was some right that was
cool
that's cool
and then i guess with teams
i had to try and i wanted to concert on
15s because i always wanted to be an all
black so was this when you were playing
you were playing for north harbour at
the time as well where yeah
yeah so i moved up from rotorua to
auckland to go
to university course north harbour
paid for my university fees which was
probably the biggest waste of money that
ever spent because i only did a year and
i thought it wasn't really for me and i
was traveling and in those days like
uni's
particularly the one i was at they
didn't
really understand the student athlete
and they weren't very
compromising on deadlines and exams and
stuff and i'm pretty stubborn and i
wouldn't you know if they said no i
would i'd always question i'm not i
wasn't really good at taking no for
answers when it was a stupid reason so i
was always like going back and
eventually i just got sick of
trying to get extensions and getting
fails and stuff and work my ass off when
i'm away and
but yeah i went up to north harbour
played one game of colts and then played
in the b team and then did a season in
the b's
we'd always play before the a team and
uh they had a harbour master with a
massive big head plastic head thing and
we'd get pissed up and at half time
you take turns running out onto the
field you're to a lap or a length across
the field and stuff and you take turns
and you see you do the stupidest things
and
i remember john buchanan we're at
counties and uh he ran across just put
the head on naked ran across the field
and back
um
the harbour master was awesome
that was that was good ones and then i
played yeah played harbor and then blues
all within sort of 12 months all
happened really quickly and what was it
like going into the blues environment
oh like mate i was playing like not
playing training with guys i'd watch
like craig dowd and
carlos spencer um
glenn taylor and robin brook
like these guys were playing for the all
blacks and i was what was now craig
guinness
made unreal and then there was guys like
me kevin milano who would [ __ ] maybe my
second year
dougie howlett you know a real young
crop of lads coming through so it was it
was pretty cool my first trip we went to
up in queensland somewhere
uh malula bar that's right for
pre-season we did a pre-season over
there john kerr was our coach and he
loved surfing so i reckon we went up
there just to surf
and um we went up there and and we did
training i don't even know if we played
we want to play the queensland up there
in a pre-season game but we had a court
session and all the young guys had to
stand up and it was it was real weird it
was like it wasn't just beer it was like
spirits and stuff like carlos and that
weren't right into drink making guys
drunk spirits and that and
i remember we're getting real real
hammered me real too pokey and mature
parkinson all of the and troy flavel and
ron krebs harbour
all the harbour lads they were pretty
pretty tight
and uh we got that piston and i came
back me and mutts came back and um
we decided to get the fire extinguishers
out
and have like a bit of a fire
extinguisher squirt war thing
but we as soon as we pulled the program
we're like yeah this is cool bit of foam
and then it just keep coming and we
couldn't put the rings wouldn't come
back it was like one of those ones you
just go and it must just empty
and these two four extensions emptied
and then the sprinklers start going off
and we're like [ __ ] and it's up to our
ankles so we just drop these things run
back to our room jump in and hopefully
it just goes away we pass out
wake up and there's
like police fire engines firemen
everything and there's just footprints
from where these things were to our room
and we're like trying to deny it not
like mate it's literally
footprints to your room it's you guys
were like no it's not us not us anyway
they had like eight
fire engines turned up the whole
everyone got evacuated like all the
alarms are going off we had to pay i
think it was about three thousand dollar
fine between years
uh each
oh [ __ ] yeah week one boys chipped in no
apparently all right all the boys
chipped down i remember fitzy was the
manager and he was like he's like no i'm
making you pay at all you know [ __ ] you
you know make make you learn a lesson
and
and well yeah whatever and um i think i
think contracts in those days were like
60 grand
yeah
for a first year so i was like well good
money but your first month or first week
and there's like your month wages gone
and uh but all the old boys pitched and
i think they all chucked them we ended
up paying a couple grand each whatever
right worth it worth it for the
fire extinguisher fight
oh my god
yeah
yeah but my first year blues was good i
played i only played like five or six
games that year and we we actually we
got like blues are going through a
transition with i guess those older guys
sort of pushing through and all the
younger guys coming through and we
didn't do that well we weren't that
consistent but
i absolutely loved it um and then
my second year really for north harbour
i played really well and peter sloane
was the blues coach and by the end and
he had said look i'm going to protect
you that you used to be able to protect
guys within your region oh no not going
to protect you so then laurie mayne's
picking me up in the draft and he rings
lorry maine's rings me and says look i
want to put you in the draft but uh not
too keen on your haircut i was like oh
yeah what do you mean he's like look
i don't know what you guys do up there
in the north island but in the south
islands we have short haircuts so if you
want to come to the highlanders
uh we'd love to have you but you need to
get a haircut because i had dreadlocks
oh yeah the dreadlocks
like
the rotorua throwback dreadlock that i
had for three or four years and
my pretty successful haircut i did
pretty
well and i was like oh far right so it
was my not my quantity but it was sort
of part of like i played the role of you
know the hard guy the
yeah
the guy that just went hard you know and
anyway so i went down to the highlanders
and um
laura means i had a haircut i just
walked into alabama and said i cut them
off and they're like you're kidding i
was like nah cut them off do you want to
keep them no i don't want to keep them i
can keep you keep them
my blonde tips had the blonde tips and
oh
it's brutal i can't believe the coach
made you cut them well he didn't make he
suggested i think
yeah
he thinks yesterday if you want to play
for the honors and you get haircut as
well i'll get haircut
and i went down to the honors mate and
fell in love with the with the whole
thing like day one bill mcewen golf
course i was in my partners with jeff
wilson
uh me and willie walker jeff wilson and
simon mayling i think was our was our
group of four on a golf course
and it was a few bears we're going
around and then go up to the golf club
afterwards right can these guys stand up
uh craig newby
willie walker billy fulton
sam harding definitely sam harding
stand up and oh [ __ ] what's going on and
i realize we're all first years and we
get a joke jug comes like eight jugs
come out there's eight of us eight jugs
come out
right this is how it works in the in the
hollanders
you do your jug in one if you take your
lips off it counts as a fail it's all
like oh [ __ ] right so i'm up second
third and do my jug
and uh that counts as one like every one
you do in a row is as you count and
that's when day one starts
and if you see how many you can get
through without someone failing
that's right and uh
we get through those eight all eight
like real good start to the season all
those eight and we're like sure this is
awesome i thought this is the island
it's like i won't be hollander forever
and then sam harding was turned 21 and a
yard glass came out and they're like
right take your shirt off yeah glass and
he does a yard glass and he chews
through it and he's vomits here and he
goes through and then
then next thing we're at paul miller's
house with kegs and my party
and then uh
went into town next morning
we had um training we had to do 3150s
and uh
well my brutal guys were being sick in
that but got through them but i remember
got uh
one of tony bullar and
joe mcdonnell and a couple of the props
mate were
just dying
i felt bad for them i was only i was a
whippet you know and like there and back
was 150 and do 30. guys were lapping
guys and i was brutal but i always
remember like this won't be i love this
place you know if you're gonna
last night a few beers meet everyone i'm
playing with guys like
tony brown and jeff wilson and
byron keller and a lot of unreal and
then
they stuck together off off the field
and then on the field they'd work their
asses off and that was my introduction
to the highlanders and i think it only
got
better
after
we had a quick every game of that year
we had a keg in the change room after
you come off the field have a keg
and um
it wasn't like you know i was what's
that
two or three beers each or whatever it
was between the whole group and squad
but
it was such a like spates was such a
thing you know like i've
always drunk lying red or whatever was
cheap really right neck or
too early or whatever but
anything mate to get it the purple
iguanas
spates was obviously such a passionate
thing about the south and they were a
big sponsor and and you learned to not
drink anything other than spates and
it was kind of like a connection thing
we'd go to south africa and everyone
would put six or twelve beers cans of
beer in their suitcase so that when we
had games or there was time there was
spates in the change room and there was
such a real connection to the people and
to the area and so i really
i really love that like it was it just
felt like when loser draw you come in
have your beer sit down
and have a yarn and talk to talk about
stuff and
i find that now like
we're pretty good here at ulster like
after a game the boys will sit down and
have a
can of coke or
whatever pepsi or whatever or heineken
and just digest but some other clubs i
know don't they just so quick get in the
showers undies on and move on so i
really enjoyed that and i try and
encourage that as a coach now that kind
of time after just a debrief just relax
you just put yourself through a war
yeah
i think i learned that through the
highlanders
yeah it's some of the best moments in
your career are those moments after a
game in the sheds and um like you say it
is said that it doesn't happen as much
as it used to but there is a balancing
act isn't there you probably don't want
to be um doing 20 jug scales after every
game either no it's such a it's
obviously moved on and i i know that you
know like it's it's unrealistic really
but you know we pick and choose now you
know you might go right we have a friday
sunday you know games and you pick and
choose and
um and the boys you know they do spend a
lot more time
with you know their families and friends
outside of rugby you know they'll get
together and they'll spend that time and
so it has changed and by all accounts
everyone's told me that you run
potentially the best cordy in world
rugby um you must have been in charge of
a few good ones down there
oh that's a
that's a lie uh kyle hoft
he runs a cordy like he's he runs a
court i probably learned everything off
him i remember just i remember writing
notes yeah i hear that recording like
speed round like all speed run right
there
muse might have been it might have been
they were my first year with props wrong
committee second year was simon mayling
john blakey
second row so it used to go through but
he caught his quarters were were a good
part of probably the end of the season
really um or if you're in south africa
and you needed just to tighten up
just a good way of
blowing the cobwebs off and aaron you
know clearing the air a little bit and
telling a few stories and in a real safe
environment but yeah we
i remember listening to your podcast on
with whopper and um
he was kind of touching on that cordy we
had at my house yeah um
that was a that was a real good real
good one uh that was my last one for the
region i suppose i don't even know yeah
it must be in highlanders and the reason
that came around is we had our
last game was on a sunday one year
and so the cordy was the monday so we
flew back from i don't know where we
flew back from and we got back on this
on the monday morning and um
tradition as you get an hour from the
airport you've got to be at carrisburg
in an hour
and if you're late it's a seven every
minute
and every
seven minutes is a jug
so you didn't want it no one's like
never really late and um
so we get there and it just gets
loose quick
and um just a regulation one i think it
started with like a hermit half does you
have to go out into the stadium and
get your half doze not out back in until
you've done your half does no talking
and you just dotted around and then you
go and it started there and then i
remember it finished um
whopper and clark dermody got the empty
keg and started smashing up this blue
table that was in the middle they used
to hold all the liniment and the briggs
and the
you know the whatever water or whatever
and they started smashing that up which
in hindsight was probably a bad thing to
do because it was like a
they've been passed down for generations
of otago rugby teams that was the oldest
thing in the change room in carriageway
it was this blue table they smashed up
and then they
started smashing the lights and it just
got out of control so we
the final straw on that day was me and
adam thompson got on the sand spreader
and we drove down to the dairy to get
some more beers and food
and we're driving down like past middle
of the road on the sand spreader that's
for the for carris brook
and the cops pull us over they're like
what are you up to lads and we're like
oh just getting some food and they're
like i suggest you
you drive back to where you came from
i.e and we're
off our tits
anyway so we then got banned
from
court sessions at calsbrook
they're like no more so there's like
there's the otago like general staff you
know like the office staff and and ceo
and they're like literally next door to
where we were and we're guys are naked
and tony brown had donated a um
a scooter he had this little red scooter
that we used to drive around and you'd
hold that big um big highlander or otago
flag and do
a naked lap as fast you get timed and
the lo there's five guys did it and this
lowest one had to do a jug it was
pretty
like basic rules you just had to get
around the four posts four corners
without falling off whatever
and uh got this is on a monday so
they're all at work and we then get
banned they're like look there's no more
cordy so we eventually our last
highlanders one we're like oh [ __ ] it
what's happen caught up on my place so i
hired a marquee
and put out in the front pad i had like
eight acres like this little i built
this house and at eight acres and
we built this put this marquee up and
everyone parked in the other paddock and
had this cordy and as wappa said there's
a car in the pond at one stage there was
guys on my quad bike i think he said
lawn mower but it was my quad bike naked
doing naked rides and um adam thompson's
car got like he came back to get it the
next morning all his tires had been
taken off and there were blocks it was
classic like once warrior was looking
stuff it was it was awesome
that was the last one but
i don't know if i ran that one or not i
think i might have just been too worried
that they were going to get into the
shed and like get the chainsaw and cut
trees down and
guys will fear away mate you're a brave
man hosting one gee especially back in
those days but it was either that or
don't have one yeah and it was worth the
risk for the cause right yeah
[ __ ]
it sounds like good times oh good times
to be a highlander back in the days but
one thing i do want to talk about is
your all black career um you did play
three tests for the all blacks well how
did you find out firstly
um
oh
real real funny like so we went to the
trials they started the trials back up i
had missed those for a few years and
this is 2004. must have been you know
after super rugby 2004 had a trial
i was in the
possibles
um so you look around you're like oh
yeah we're not making it
and uh
so we played and made we almost took
them up like they were they were stacked
with all the the incumbents and we
almost took them up and
we played well i thought i've personally
played really well but i was you know up
against godzilla richie and um
marty holler you know there's some
pretty good sevens around
uh josh blacky maybe
didn't make the original side so i flew
off to fiji on holiday
and um
i went home for the weekend before i
flew away on holiday and i'd i was
cutting some wood up in the shed i don't
know what i was doing building a dog box
i think i cut my
top of my thumb off on a on a table saw
and i remember mum took me to a e and
they stitched me all up and
went to fiji on a monday and i'm on the
bears i was over with my partner at the
time but
friends and stuff and we're just having
a real good time in fiji
and i got a phone call i don't know
maybe
middle of week one or something and that
was darren shand
saying oh craig richie's been injured or
something can you you know we'd like you
to come into the all blacks can you be
here this afternoon and i said oh look
i'm actually in rotorua
just uh you know a bit of r r so can i
come in tomorrow and he's like yeah
sweet see you at nine o'clock whatever
and i thought i had to catch a flight
back and i had this burning my thumb i
couldn't swim
i was like swimming around like this
with a plastic bag on and that and i
couldn't bend it and it was pretty
rooted so i remember
our physio from harbor dave beatty his
wife was a hand specialist
so she i got out of the airport went
around to her place and she made me this
like plastic molding cast so to put my
thumb sort of like in a position that
they wouldn't split
the stitches in that
turn up the training
get a load of kit go straight at the
training and that might have been
tuesday or something and then we played
england on saturday second test at eden
park you're on the bench sweet
into it didn't know anything didn't know
the calls didn't really oh no i felt
like i wasn't really meant to be there
yeah
and i was i was sitting here i'm not
going to get on and marty holler got
injured or blood bin or something and i
went on and
later was pretty
it just happened so quick yeah um
i don't even know how maybe 20 minutes
and then
game was over and we'd won and it just
happened so quick and and i hadn't
prepared for it because i knew i've been
so disappointed about not making it and
yeah you know i thought i'd had a really
good shot and then after the game got my
tie from tana he was captain and graeme
henry's like wet on son
you know did really well out there
thanks very much richie's going to be
right for next week so uh
all the best mate shook my hand and all
the best and
awesome
toys
so then i went out and spent all my
match fee
on my mates i had like a dozen mates
there and spent all my beer all my money
on on them and had an awesome night out
and then the next day
get a phone call rich is not quite right
can you come in on uh can you come in
and i was like yeah and i had to like
try and make up some excuse because i
was hungover and
went back in and ended up sort of
staying in and out for that whole year
did it always feel like a real temporary
thing being involved then
i think um
i think that initial bit like that if it
was england and then they
re-selected for the tri-nations and once
i got re-selected properly for the
tri-nations so that first initial bit
was like real cover and i was like just
living day by day and
just trying to enjoy it for what it was
and then
uh you know trying to put my best foot
forward i suppose and
and then once i got named in the
trinations that was like [ __ ] awesome
you know like i was
i sort of personally felt like i
belonged there but i never really did i
always felt
i always felt i didn't quite
fit or i didn't quite get the love you
know they talk about the good people and
all that and i i kind of felt
i was on the out of the outer of that
and i didn't really get the benefit of
that whole
change of mindset yeah so that was my
first year and then i didn't play 2005
so the lions yeah i didn't get selected
i was playing really i thought i was
playing really good footy and didn't get
selected i was pretty despondent played
for otago against the lions which was
pretty magic and
captained captain otago against the
lions
was my first game for otago so i just
transferred from north harbour and got
sick of moving up and down so i
transferred and um
played good footie i didn't make the all
blacks that yeah i played for the junior
all blacks i think it was 2005 and then
didn't play the lions thought you know
kind of over in 2006
i must have gone okay again and got got
in which was probably more frustrating
because i i think i
i was training really well i knew what
was going on i was really confident in
that
environment and i was on the bench for
i think eight games didn't get a start
but on the bench for eight games and
only got on three times or you know i
only had three tests and i felt that was
really like heartbreaking you know like
you worked so hard and felt like i had
loads to offer and
didn't get that opportunity
and then my last i knew it was my last
test was against argentina and we i was
on the bench with me flabs jimmy cowan
luke luke mcallister it's funny i can't
remember these names like yesterday but
it has come back flooding today and um
boys were getting toweled up by the rg's
like scott hamilton's first test he
scored a try and i said it was like
quite close i think we're winning by a
couple of points and i was like we're
amping to get on all the bench we're
amping let's go on and we can try and
lift the tempo or whatever we can do and
i didn't get on
and i remember just going oh that's
that's me done that's my last test i
reckon so i um
i went back to the change room spat the
dummy again threw my jersey in the bin
and just got changed and just jumped on
the team bus
i remember wayne smith saying hey what's
wrong with you i thought mate just let
you know i'm pretty disappointed not to
get on again you know like i feel like
i've got a really added value today and
he's like oh yeah you just got to be
patient or something which was good he
was an awesome awesome man like he
wasn't malicious about it and always
just like pretty philosophical and like
may just be patient keep working or
whatever um and then anton oliver gave
him he picked my jersey at him out of
the bin and said to me um this was
the next day and he said you'll you
might want this and he gave it back to
me that was it that was my last one and
then the next year still playing good
footie didn't even make the junior all
blacks so i was like this is
nah that's not for me i'm gonna go and
do something different
and that's when i got the opportunity to
come over to leicester wow well look for
the opportunity and took it
crazy and then how did you find the uh
english premiership
i loved it
well i absolutely loved it um
my last game for
a good story wapa loves the story but
last game honda's in africa was against
the cheetahs in bloomfinteen
and uh we had a real good win 30-odd to
late 20s like awesome game
two battler teams you know like real
battlers play good footy just rip it and
then
remember glenn moore he was coaching
he's here like boys awesome win um we're
gonna stay off the bears
um we've got a big game next week
against the blues at home
traditionally teams you know that travel
don't really do well in their first game
back and we need to win it and blah blah
and i was sitting there and i'm captain
i'm sitting there ah [ __ ]
great speech growler but uh hey boys
last thing for me is uh just gonna let
you know i've um i've signed a contract
in leicester i'll be going on a two-year
deal at the end of the season so this is
my last
time i'll be in south africa as a group
um i've booked a book the van for eight
o'clock anyone wants to be there we're
going to i don't know whatever public
it's called that cuban yeah had
organized
and you see his face going
just disappointed in me
and everyone's like yeah quiet quiet at
eight o'clock at 7 59 there was 26 out
of the 28 boys in a 12 seater van like
rammed the only two that went there was
chris king and paul williams and
everyone just went in and just went
mental like best night ever like same as
an elliot dixon story like couldn't get
people out including me like we're just
going real hard
and then um it got to like
five o'clock and the only way we got out
is because me whopper tom donnelly
and clint newlins were going hunting the
next morning and we had to be in the van
that's this was a couple hours away
so we got back at like half past five
still steaming jumped in this van
wearing shorts and t-shirt thing in
south africa it's going to be boiling
get out to the middle of nowhere and
it's raining
freezing cold and well oh so we sat in
this hot drinking whiskey to keep warm
we got so wet
we just had to pull pin
and then clint ellen shot this massive
eland or something and we chased that
around for about
two hours because it he hadn't hit it
properly
and me and wappa the guy
for some reason decided that me and
wappa could drive his hilux so i'm
driving the hilux waffles in the front
seat box of beers
and we're driving around following the
front ute which sas and
critter were on trying to get this eland
and we're driving around
drinking beers off-road so obviously not
drink driving because i don't condone
that
and then all of a sudden we must have
fallen asleep or
looking at something and we just
bam
smash straight into the back of the
other you
all right and the guys are falling off
there's like this
whole tailgate's caved in we had these
bull bars in the whole tailgate and
we're like [ __ ] whatever there when you
get out in the it's just like
nose to tail and the guy's like what
happened oh
the brakes something's wrong with the
brakes so you better check the brakes
and so the guy's like mate you guys
you can't drive so he got out and
and that was it and then we drove back
that was my last thing and then um
yeah flew i played the rest of the
season flew over in
uh
october i think it was
and uh i loved the premiership it was a
real grind about 30 games in a row you'd
know mate like it's
but i loved it like we were a really
good side and we're in europe
competitions which is really different
for new zealanders you know playing home
and away and oh so good man the stadiums
are unbelievable and i really enjoy the
rugby that we played like it was really
like
my defensive stuff i could just make 30
tackles a game and i was really valued
like all those core things like you
catch past that kiwis take for granted
like they were really valued at
leicester and i became a real like
leader
in lots of different areas and
and i was just there for that like
obviously the money was really good and
and and the lifestyle change and i just
wanted to play good footy and and i end
up playing better rugby just because the
fact i was playing free and i started i
know i met just some really good
different people like the english guys
are you know like they love a bear and
they love like working really hard and
it just sort of clicked for three or
four years and
um we want to want a few things and
made a few good mates you know real good
mates yeah one game i do want to touch
on is the famous infamous uh final
against cardiff where you
step up to the 22 slot your kick mate
what was your heart rate like lining
that one up oh
yes the context was it was a semi-final
and we were
like we were pumping them in normal time
and they scored two converted tries ben
blair from the sideline
xavier rush was playing for them ben
blair two conversions from sideline draw
it up extra time
um
draw it extra time and went went to
penalty shootout and it was from in
front and i was always i always back
myself with goal kicking like i used to
always kick after training i had some
real good guys i
kicked with with through my career front
ebotica when i started and
willie walker then nick evans and tony
brown and then when i got over to
leicester with toby flood and derek
coogard
i used to just competition with him all
the time and so i kind of i wanted to be
in the top five i was like look i'm
better than some of these other guys so
can i be like three
and paul burke was up in case you're
like no news will save you for the back
you know i was like mate um aaron
major's back was wrecked he was like the
number six
scott hamilton wore gilbert boots he was
number five i mean how can a guy wearing
gilbert boots be higher than me
and
johnny murphy who was like a awesome
bloke but he um
he was real emotional and i was like
he's number four he's definitely gonna
miss i'll go i'll go four
and he's like no you'll go
like seven
seven
anyway gets down to it and then i i i go
up there and the only thing i was
stressing about is i hadn't bought my
tea oh yeah so i um had to borrow
someone else's today and i was like
[ __ ] like [ __ ] of it it was one of
those i wore i used the telescopic one
yeah i like used to like it quite high
just get the levers through and and i
just had to kick off one of those little
stubby ones i was worried about that
just hitting the grass but just whacked
it through and then
as it turns out martin williams like the
greatest welsh flanker ever missed his i
felt like it's horrible for him but then
jordan crane our guy got it and
yeah that was cool unbelievable scenes
that i was so so hardcoded it was the
only time
people sometimes ask you
like playing in front of big crowds now
what's it like do you hear it and you're
like you never do like it's always just
a buzz you hear the odd bit and you hear
cheering and maybe booing and stuff but
um that was the only game i've ever
heard like the crowd while i've been
like literally playing here in the crowd
and the all-english crowd was singing um
sweet chariot and all the welsh were
singing bread of heaven and it was just
like a
right just merging songs for the whole
game it was like
unbelievable um that was one of my
favorite games most memorable games hey
it looked it was one of those great ones
yeah yeah so good we're playing um
toulouse this week in the return game
and it's aggregate over two games
and uh the there's a kickoff thing in
that if uh if it gets to points and
tries and all that but i think it
probably won't get to that but
boys are talking about it today can
coaches step up
nah oh man i can't even
touch the nose let alone kick a ball
right if it's a boat race i'll step
another team i love hearing the stories
about is the barbarians and i know you
had a
good time in the barbarians scoring a
try but then
looked like you broke your neck yeah
yeah we were again we we went two
barbarians during the week and and had a
lot of beers we had a pretty good side
but
we're getting pumped island and i scored
a try and i didn't break my neck but i
sort of jarred my neck and i knew
something was wrong like most rugby
footy guys you get up and you're like
i'll walk it off or even if it's bad you
can still sort of and i was like not
something not quite right
and i just
as it turned out i spent three days
across the hospital you know like not to
screw on things but a halo and watching
tv through a mirror and
all alone like no family no friends
around it was really surreal um
luckily i already got my 10 grand cash
um in an envelope on day one so i was
like mate where's my cash and they're
like yeah you don't really cash
and uh
i ruptured three discs in my neck and um
so i'd spend a bit of time on the
sidelines but
oh the bar bars was was pretty pretty
cool pretty special i've actually tried
to i've contacted them a few times to
see if i get some guest coaching
gigs with them but they're like yeah
yeah
but they actually sent me last year i
noticed they
on the jerseys the plane just is in the
number they have everyone like the four
former players they sent me a jersey
last year or the year before which is uh
the blue emailed and said hey we want to
send you jersey and
pretty cool club to be part of yeah the
best thing about that was tom donnelly
was meant to be with me he's me to fly
over and then he got called into the all
blacks and they're like oh we need you
to cover and it's all right sweet i'll
come and cover and he did like two days
covering
like whoever had no chris jack or
something
two days of covering went to
like a week and i think two weeks in
england got 10 grand cash
and
he didn't even get to bloody come over
and i remember that i got back from the
airport drove straight to his house
and i just i dropped him off i said oh i
might just off to the bank i also i've
just got to take this money into the
bank
eight grand cash it's been a couple but
he was like get [ __ ] out of my house
get the [ __ ] out
wait that's good oh that's so good and
we spoke about your sort of retirement
and coaching um at the start but what
are what are the plans for you going
forward uh keep learning like my
coaching's hard um there's so many
awesome times and i absolutely love it
and i think
for me it's just keep learning um i've
just signed a new two-year deal here so
i'll be in belfast for another two years
and really really good group our head
coach dan mcfarlane's like an
outstanding head coach on learning loads
i'd love to become a defense coach or a
ford's coach of you know whether it's
here or or other opportunities
i'd say england or you know the europe's
probably my my thing my wife's english
so i kind of got some advice here my
daughter's uh
got two years left at high school over
here and
she'll go to university over here so i'm
sort of that's probably where i'm going
to be for the time being
but yeah pretty loose sort of plans in
terms of my coaching just keep learning
and keep enjoying it
i've got some personal goals outside of
footy that i want to achieve but there
for another day really how good is that
love it well what a story what a career
so many good diesel stories in there um
i'm sure the wodley listeners will be
loving that but as always we've gone to
our instagram for some questions and
mate you have a lot of friends who
follow what a lad obviously and plenty
of good questions have come in for you
here
our first question
what happened to tom donnelly when he
tried to charge the back
oh the whole back seat
uh
yeah he he got a split lip
uh
when i first started for the hondas it
was like the back seat of
hofton
oliver and
muse you know some big dog old school
and i learned
the fast way of
you know the back seat was kind of uh
the leadership group i suppose in some
symbolic way was
that and getting to the back seat was
always a big thing and i remember it was
otago in the season trip i think and i
think i would like to just get everyone
up and make a charge for it and i didn't
even know if i was on the back seat or i
was sort of one one in front or not but
i can't remember and he just came in and
i just put one down
oh yeah
you guys are good friends away oh best
mates still best mates
yeah you obviously got him good though
oh i don't know
it was one of those i didn't
see any faces just sort of just saw a
bloke
okay good stuff okay next one
um where does he get the nickname soupy
from oh um
i just used to enjoy
the social side of footy and the thing i
said earlier is like
play it work hard play hard drink hard
you know and
hong kong soupy was a uh
like a real
shitty cartoon
superhero when i was a kid growing up
and uh the boys called me hong kong
soupy
and uh just sort of went really well
yeah i think i was just like a product
of like whoever was at the front of the
charge most of the time or whoever's the
leader and
you know i guess because i was captain
for a lot of those years that um i was
always for
always for it boys letting off a bit of
steam and enjoying each other's company
sounds like good times okay the next one
tell us about the stuart island off
season trips
also stewart island's obviously down the
bottom and we used to go down there um
after each season and book a hut on a
dockland and um
it was probably early in my hunting
career like carl haymon got me into
hunting and yeah we'd go down there and
just drink beers for a few days one of
the best ones was we i think we had 15
cans of beer a day each was an
allocation we had to get through it and
there was me glenn horton tahim and tom
donnelly charlie hall was always there
tim boyce whopper
good crew and uh
one of the best ones we stayed because
the allocation we called it was so high
we brought in the sema rule if you got a
can that had the seam down the mouth yet
you had to scroll that and
each day two blokes had to um
were designated non-hunters
so
you had to try and get through double
your allocation just to get just get
ahead of it and everyone else would go
hunting and fishing and stuff and me and
charlie hall were on one day and uh
we got um we got pretty pretty hammered
and the boys went out for a hunt came
back and then they decided let's go for
a dive
so some reason me and charlie jumped on
the boat on
zara carl hammond's um on zog's stably
craft and we jumped out there and they
went for a dive and we went we were two
pests we're drinking beers and
we decided they were down for a while
and we decided look we we're gonna go
do a bit of fishing and so we chucked
the keys in
in ignition and and went for it and
we're burning around and the boys reckon
they could all i can hear is like
like just they were in the water
obviously you just see this like
outboard just zooming past and we're
apparently doing laps and
um
i was then they were too scared to come
up and then eventually we calmed down a
bit but
that was um that was one story but i
don't think we were there like four
years or something and i think we're the
only person who shot a deal was carl and
that was off the boat
um we saw a few but uh it was real
social another time me and whopper jamie
mcintosh fell asleep we got it real
early we fell asleep on the beach
and we missed completely all the the
deer hunting we woke up and there's this
massive big seal sea lion on the beach
of 100 meters down then we're like
contemplating like so what would we have
to do to consider shooting that light so
we went into survival mode we went like
bear grylls and we decided that we'd
walk to this other hut and spend a whole
day like pretending to be survivor men
and
in the end we didn't see any deer we
didn't do any surviving but we just um
we think the boys were meant to pick us
up on a boat and they forgot about us
but that was always a good um end of
year blowout and i think
um we've got plans to get back down
there at some stage
mate that is a hell of a time
and what a crew you had jeez there's
some lads in there oh man i could go for
weeks on the on stewart island the one
of the bigger ones
was we ran out of ran out of beer one
day
and so we uh radioed into the guy that
had brought us over we raided in
um and he was in open which was about
two hours around from the hut we're at
and we um we paid the guy a thousand
dollars to take us to obama
um to pick up more beers and we got to
the to the jetty and open we'd all
ordered through the um pub there and
they dropped off like boxes and boxes of
beers we didn't even get on shore we
just scoot them off off the wall chucked
them back in and we we it was a five and
a half hour round trip just to get
another like doesn't be easy
for a day i was awesome
awesome oh the yarns the yarns mate
bucketless material going to stewart
island with craig newby mate sounds like
one of the greats anyway next question
is what's your best scott hamilton yarn
oh scotty hamilton what a legend he's
actually just retired eventually he's
been
director of rugby and still playing for
hinckley which are in national one or
two over in england uh he's just retired
so what a bloke um what a man and what a
friend you know real good we came to the
lit to leicester three weeks apart he
stayed with me for a bit until he got
his house sorted so we've been mates for
as long as we've i've been over in over
in the uk
uh some good ones uh i'll go real quick
kasabian were in town in leicester local
local band pretty good and he was like
we're all going and he put on twitter
uh hey guys like the old thumbs up hey
guys everyone i'm coming to kasabia and
catch you there later on
and uh
a 12 year old lad filmed him at kasabian
at 11 in the morning so he'd only been
there an hour
he's on a honest and john's gurney
passed out vomit just sick as a dog
and the 12 year old would won like a
selfie when selfies when a thing is like
hey mate found you
and
where's the story was he had to pay the
kid off from putting up releasing in
that but that was a good one
he'd done oh we went to the races one
time and um
we have a few ascot royal ascot it was
awesome like quality 25 degrees they're
on a short t-shirt and scotty's there
and getting a bit loose and
um we went to leave and we're like no
one nowhere where's scotty like there's
a big group of us where's scotty look we
can't leave a man down there's thousands
of people there and we no no phone
signal not answers phone
and there's a band in the background
everyone's having a great time and then
all of a sudden we're like look over and
he's up on stage with the band singing
john farnham you're the voice let's go
we're trying to open that little crowd
surfing back but they didn't eventually
found them and then um
our attack coach dan soper is a kiwi guy
he
came to the 2009 heineken cup final that
we played against leinster in
murrayfield he came on it as a stag dude
and he went up there thursday friday he
didn't know scott didn't know me
thursday friday stag do saturday was the
match three o'clock
he met bumped into us
saturday night 8 p.m and we'd obviously
lost the final to leinster
and he said he'd been on the purse for
three days and scott hamilton was just
still the drunkest bloke in edinburgh
wonder what sort of thing like three
hours ago and squashed the drunks guys
oh my i need to get him on one lad he
sounds like an absolute lead i love that
one okay next question is what's the
best stadium in the premiership uh
welford road right hands down just
real close passionate real loud when
you're winning when you're losing which
wasn't that often when i was playing but
like just
mega mega place um franklin's gardens
northampton was really good uh down in
gloucester was really good
not the shed you know they used to they
used to get get stuck up to leicester
that was a real real cool one um
yeah some real good ones they like sandy
park down in exeter once they came in
they they're a fortress down there
um
one of the we used to mostly before um
before games i was a bit quite casual
guys were out like banging walls or out
there kicking or passing i was always
just asking to kick in and
i used to um me and tom vandals or when
we used to just kick the ball and do
like back passes and then richard cocker
used to lose it he's like why are these
guys mucking around and we're like let's
just probably relax i remember tom
vandal used to send balls into the crowd
and we'd pick out like especially at
away games we'd pick out
like a like home fans and would just try
and send a ball into them and he he one
day just this this lady was carrying
like four bears walking through this
thing and he just like i'm gonna when he
targets this lady trying to knock her
bears off hit him straight in the face
she went down
bears everywhere when i oh [ __ ] we just
turned around
oh good times oh love it
were you like that in the all black
environment no no way i was nowhere near
i didn't enjoy those small things in the
all blacks you know i just it was
business it was
representing everyone you know your
country and yourself and your family so
i didn't really
didn't really and i never really felt
comfortable in the playing environment
to actually express myself
as much as i would if i was in the
highlanders or the otago or just my you
know local club whatever so
but i think it
deserved that respect you know i didn't
think um it was the place to do a lot of
those things yeah fair enough okay next
one ah
i'm sure there'll be plenty of these but
what is your favorite all-time quarter
oh
i can't remember any specific one i
remember the one time in new south wales
we played um
and
we were philippe levy had a fight with
justin harrison and got sent off
and we were back well we
we were just just good blokes who ripped
in and
we were down by a few points and i'm
sure it was matt saunders or glenn
horton or both of them scored like a
couple of tries each just out of nowhere
and we just like fought our way back
and
matt burke had a kick to win it from 40
out last play of the game and it hit the
post and neil brew caught it kicked it
off and we went mental and
and we had a um
we went into darling there's a darling
harbour
excuse me and we had to call you in
there at the seafood restaurant and we
just took over this whole place and just
said that's awesome like it wasn't
really that boring it was just like a
few speed rounds and some finds and
that was always a memorable one and then
uh
yeah that was that was pretty cool i
remember roy kinnick
when he first came in and he just i
remember
something stuck out in your mind and he
was like um
oh this is how we do a jug and wally and
then he just took two hours to do his
jug we just might sit in the corner
it could be a book about your court
sessions okay next one why did you
always wear an eddie desktop big baggy
denim jeans and edit their shoes when
you went to town
well mate baggy jeans had baby pockets
so keep all the cash probably a random
can of spates in each pocket and
i don't know that was probably just
growing up in river i don't even
remember wearing baggy jeans and that to
town but and i was sponsored by adidas
you know they were um
they were pretty good to me so i guess
mata was tight though in those days that
he's tight so
you don't get nothing
fair enough okay next one does he still
wear g-strings
i've never ever worn a g-string
um
eric rush made up the story that i used
to wear g-strings and then there's
aftermath speeches and and presentations
you always say oh it introduced guys and
you'd be like this is carl tanana his
nicknames the abc or whatever and
this noobs and his nickname is the g-man
because he can wear a g-string backwards
brutal way like it was such a good like
no comeback
but no i never wore g-strings
so that's just fully made up you just
had to run with it yeah
that was one of the the best ones i
can't remember it was but he used to say
um
he used to use little like nicknames
like that one was the sledge
by the sled he's oh yeah and this is
craig newby the sled has you know and
they're like oh what's he called the
sled and like he's called the sled
because when he was at school he was
always getting pulled by dogs [ __ ] he
was good oh that's hardcase okay next
one oh there'll be a few of these two
i'd imagine best tony woodcock yarn uh
woody
me and him a really good mate best mates
we've been great mates for
the minute i became a north harbour guy
um
one of the best ones uh the best one was
we
came back from northland and he he
decided that we're going to drink a 24
pack on the way back from northland to
north harbour which is you know like
some some doing two hours or whatever
two and a half hours
and so we're chipping away and he was a
he's a steady drinker
and uh we're chipping away and he i just
remember him standing up to tellyarn and
the bus mustered like there must have
been
some sheep on the road or something and
it just slammed his brakes on at 100k an
hour and he just went from back to the
front also that's it all the way down
i enjoyed that one okay the next one
what was louis moody like to play with
few english fans yeah louis moody oh um
just relentless like he was such a
leader in
in his intensity and effort and it was
infectious so we we played a bit of six
and seven and then
he um made like charge downs and hidden
rocks and um
any loose balls scraps on the ground
just those kind of things he was the
world leader in anything he's also the
world leader of getting cut like he
would be cut every game we played a game
of touch in a warm up one day and he
dove like he was fully on diving around
and he'd go for a ball and he hit
alessandra to a lungi
and he broke his leg and a warm-up game
of touch on it like a tuesday mcdonald's
isn't a game real good
for moodles
yeah
okay next one who was the best player
you ever played with this will be tough
because you obviously played with some
legends
uh oh jonah not hands down general's the
best player i've ever played with
just
just a freak you know um particularly
simmons in 15s it probably would have
been
tony brown
uh just the most influential on a team
in a game like you see his leadership as
a coach now he's just making
good blokes into great players and and
good teams into great teams and and
he did that as a player so brownie
stands out jeff wilson was ridiculous
when i was a kid you know like watching
him doing stuff and then getting to play
with him so
probably those three stand out oh yeah
good shouts all of them okay last
question best piece of advice you have
for a water lead listener
best piece of advice oh
i think um
if you want something go and get it go
and find a way to get it write some
ideas down
and make it happen don't sit around and
and just let the world go by or other
people have stuff you know like the
grass is not always greener on the other
side so just
if you want something go and rip into it
and make it happen and
and be patient i think a lot of people
these days and particularly younger
generation like my teenage daughter and
her friends and that but a bit impatient
just
go and work and work work and if it
doesn't if one
opportunity doesn't work out go and find
another one but that would probably be a
bit of advice really just going
if you want it go and get it
oh mate i love that and that is why you
are a coach jesus ulster lads are lucky
having information and advice like that
on tap whenever they want it mate what a
coach oh you never know mate they uh
they're pretty they're pretty good here
i'm really lucky they're self-driven and
and i just
you know like i just turn up basically
i'm just the guy that turns up when they
when they ask him
and that's all i think my role here is
you know a big big part of that is just
giving them time nice love it
anyway mate really appreciate you coming
on the podcast um sharing some of these
yarns one of the best podcasts today um
so many good stories so many good yarns
and i'm sure the listeners will have
enjoyed that one all the best with the
rest of your coaching career and i'll be
following it very closely thanks mate
awesome love it love your work keep the
work up mate some good blokes coming on
here i'll get you scott hamilton's
number yeah cheers mate that'd be good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stuff what
[Music]